your Russian accent is so good but I'm
wondering is that a hard accident to
learn cuz it seems like it would be you
know I mean any accent that's that
different from your own is challenging
for sure but you know I mean as an actor
there's like nowadays in the 24 surgery
there's so many sort of helpful things
like you've got YouTube the internet
stuff like that so you just go on and
just type into YouTube Russian and
you'll find someone speaking Russian or
you find a native Russian speaking
English you're struggling to speak
English when you kind of you just listen
to it you go okay
hours and hours and hours literally on
YouTube yeah just watching yeah anything
that with anyone the Russian accent
Russia yeah pretty much
and that and then you go okay well that
bat vowel is kind of ubiquitous through
all of them and so is that consonant and
the way they dentalized their tea okay
I'll borrow that you know it all kind of
sounds Russian to me I guess right I
just love that if my wife walked in and
I was that long in the computer I'd be
like I'm studying for my role and of
course if you spend that long on YouTube
you end up going down like a deep
wormhole and you end up on weird videos
yes you do yeah it's no good I didn't
you leave YouTube and you go other
places
was there one was there one was there
would you say that there was one clip
that you found or that helped you the
most that you sort of felt like okay
that's it that's the accident I want
yeah you know there was there was
there's one I mean there's a ton of
stuff easier like all over the place but
there was one guy I found a massage
therapist who I actually worked with
before I got no car accident I messed up
my neck and they sent me to this guy and
he's just a character and so I was like
he has such a beautiful old Russian
accent that's very period I was like I
love this guy Boris pre Luke's Keys
accent and he's got all these videos of
him he's got like massage videos where
it's like self massage and out of like
feel yourself how'd it happen massage
yourself yeah that's all right
naturally come on sure it's amazing
people need videos for that yeah I mean
I must be a prodigy Andy's the chosen
one
we have you actually brought I told you
brought it's too good to miss yeah you
have to see that this is what you were
studying to prepare for your role in
mana but this is I love this let's take
a look like this with fingers you can
leave a lubrication to food and with
fish like they decide oh this is big
beard the whole thing let's see another
one I want another one
yeah you see even if you difficult and
this is canon babe a cream can you can
like this grabbing random objects he's
just grabbing any it's very fitting by
the way all rising Harry yeah